Hi, welcome back. So far in this class we covered
a lot of programming techniques, but we mostly
done it with small examples of code. In this unit,
we’re going to look at a larger example than
anything we seen before. We’re going to write
an algorithm for finding the highest scoring play
in a crossword tile game. Now, versions of this
game go by names like Scrabble and Words
with Friends. So we’re going to have to represent
everything about the words, the tiles, the board,
the scoring and the algorithm for finding the
highest scoring word. That’s going to be more code
I’m going to be writing a lot of it and you’re going to
get practice reading, that’s an important skill but I’m
also going to stop and leave you plenty of places
where you can write some other code and at any
point, if you want a bigger challenge, you can stop
the video and go ahead yourself and try to solve as
much of it as you can on your own and I would
encourage you to do that. This is a big step-up.
I think you are all ready for it. So let’s get started.